[Music]
i've always felt like climate change is
the defining issue of this generation
my passion for the environment and
conservation more broadly definitely
stem from my love of climbing
i think as a climber you wind up with a
unique perspective on climate because
you spend so much time outside up high
on the sides of cliffs looking down on
things
it gives you a vantage point that the
average tourist driving through the park
doesn't necessarily see
[Music]
my name is alex arnold i'm a
professional rock climber i've basically
spent the last 20 plus years climbing
outside all the time and you just can't
spend that much time outdoors without
starting to care about the environment
and trying to protect the wild places
that you climate
[Music]
they're the basic things as a climber
like leaving no trace making sure you
don't make a mess of the crag try not to
create the environment more than you
have to really i think the climbing
lifestyle is relatively low impact
except that you're constantly traveling
between different climbing areas if you
go to an area stay there for at least a
[Music]
month i don't think there was one
specific moment as a climber that made
me realize that the climate was changing
i've traveled fairly widely i've just
seen quite a bit and so have a lot of
different examples from different parts
of the world the polar regions in
particular but also just the high
mountains with glaciated peaks are
really where the world is changing the
fastest when you look at these peaks
that seem permanent and then you see
that the glaciers are just retreating so
quickly that it changes the way you
interact with the mountains and that
just strikes you as wrong you normally
think of those types of landscapes as
sort of transcending human time frames
and yet just in the time that i've been
a climber i've seen them change
drastically
so i went to eat somebody a bunch as a
kid
but then my first time climbing there i
was 18 or 19.
you know i've been climbing yosemite for
15 years
and now it's unimaginably hot to climb
there in june or september the
comfortable climbing season has shifted
months on either side it is slightly
hard to plan for as a climber now you
should just anticipate that any kind of
ice route may or may not be in and you
should know that when you hike into the
mountains like that there's a good
chance that it's just not going to be in
condition things are changing pretty
quickly and you just don't totally know
as a result of my travel experience as a
climber and seeing how quickly the world
is changing i started the haunted
foundation which supports solar projects
around the world
so sometimes that means solar panels on
a school for indigenous girls in
guatemala with solar-powered boats in
the amazon grid tied solar systems in
the u.s in low income communities and
basically all kinds of different systems
i think that
it's hard for people that live in cities
to appreciate how quickly
things are changing in the more
remote and rugged places on earth for me
personally as as a climber and as an
athlete
i like to show
the natural surroundings that i'm
climbing in and so edge of the unknown
is a new national geographic series
showing
how top athletes do what they do
and it allows folks at home an
opportunity to see some of the edges of
earth that you're just not seeing
normally
in my case my episode is sort of a
deeper dive into this experience we had
climbing walls in morocco and it's
exactly the kind of place that is most
affected by climate particularly because
it's north africa and so it's already
climatically extreme cold in winter hot
in the summer it's up high these are the
types of communities that are most
affected by climate change and the
people who are at least able to adapt
when you read statistics about climate
refugees these are the communities that
you're reading about i hope that anyone
watching edge of the known comes away a
little bit inspired about
how we do the sports that we do and the
hard work that goes into performing at
this level but i hope that they're also
inspired by the natural beauty of the
world and the locations in which we're
doing these sports
when i think about the world that my
child will eventually inhabit i prefer
to think that it could actually be great
if humanity chooses to rise to the
occasion and meet some of these
challenges we just haven't quite chosen
to take that path yet but the optimist
in me just feels like you may as well at
least think about the ways in which you
can improve the world by acting on
climate and i think that's the more
tenable path forward
[Music]
[Applause]